ma buongiorno amici miei bellissimi cari
che stiamo per iniziare una roba che mi
state consigliando da una vita perché
allora voi tutti
se siete assidui frequentatori del mio
canale e lo siete perché se non lo siete
andate a confessarmi premi invio sul mio
canale ho portato un sacco di serie di
successo perché ce l'ho giocata io
quindi hanno avuto successo da e smetto
di tirarmela che tanto la ragazza ce
l'ho l'ho trovata comunque a parte le
cagate ho portato sul mio cane un sacco
di serie che sono piaciute e questa e
una di essere che è piaciuta in assoluto
di più che è la serie di harry stickman
hanno fatto uscire dopo anni il gioco
ufficiale su steam che ha revisionato
tutte quante queste mappe che avevo già
giocato col magari aggiunte che io non
so a parte io non me lo ricordo proprio
però magari hanno aggiunto proprio delle
robe extra quindi direi che possiamo
rifarci un l'ex play totale di harry
stickman polaris hickman collection
partendo dal primo che breaking bad bank
per un giorno mi ricordo niente però c'è
ristic m la storia da seguire gli aerei
stigma che tenta di si parte subito va
bene deve entrare nella banca quale fa
parte fatto che sto gioco a 6 milioni di
b b che puoi utilizzare in che modo
entriamo in banca direi con qualche modo
la roma un po più easy che breaking dawn
non mi ricordo quali se quale sono state
le mie vecchie scelte ma fa niente tanto
salve non sono per niente sospetto c'è
solo una gru ma avete ordinato a noi
facciamo laser non avete ordinato la gru
ma sicuramente la droga che ti cade
addosso io te l'ho detto poi sono cazzi
tuoi
apriti se essa può magari in modo giusto
e l'esplosivo visto che nessuno sentirà
il botto ma proprio nei credono e secco
bravo
però mi ci ritrovo un sacco ci sembro io
quando faccio le cose uguale con la
cacchio di pala 4 4 su 6 almeno al
quarto che ci debba giocare sì ma la
fisica che ti insegna anche piero angela
che se scarne che scavi sotto scava e
poi vai ad è mai verso la banca seno che
cazzo scavi cioè disguise o bellissimo
per forse quello giusto perché erano
tutti sbagliati quindi va bene ok siamo
entrati ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta
mi hanno buttato in mezzo ad del cerume
che cos'è sta roba è una roba hai fatto
da solo una roba hai fatto da solo che
non ho cliccato è sbagliato niente
finito il gioco
spero che vi sia piaciuto the story
begins esordire a episodi uno ischia
fine prisa lava e quella era quello era
il prologo va bene niente lasciamo stare
scrive escaping prison mi sembra
corretto e flickr
sei libero di andare via per il culo in
realtà non ho mai ricevuto un bayern non
hanno controllato che cosa c'è dentro
hanno fatto malissimo perché all'interno
c'è tensione la torta ah no ed è certo
ma ovviamente nessuna torta cosa ci deve
trovare sta roba perché per forza
abbiamo un miliardo di cose stavolta
prodotte le porte perché è l'unico
oggetto che avevo anche prima ma vediamo
che succede stavolta sottratto alla
banca allora parco che perfetto nrg
drink to me va bene sono fortissimo e
tuttora bordo
cosa sto facendo salve adesso che sei è
la madonna
l'ho buttato nel cestino va bene ma
muoviti che non sono tuttora l'effetto
sono uscito e stato divertente bene
adesso un infarto ecco lo sapeva gli
effetti collaterali sono nausea mal di
testa ma lì è accaduto ma li testa vale
tutto il resto che non so tradurre
quindi dico tutto il resto è troviamo il
drill giusto per finire dove non voglio
finire al centro della terra
probabilmente ne so già come va a finire
ogni volta lo so erano i bagni buono già
fatta per a quello giusto deduco che
fosse l'altra umana la cosa giusta nel
tombino va bene giorno giovanna giorgio
van straten ce la faccio a fare più di
una roba oddio era una roba da fare in
velocità ma figurati se mi ricordo e io
scrivo a non ce n'è un altro nostro che
immagino ci siano altri successo a tema
dove dorsista e lo ha schiacciato
devo sfondare la porta con la testa
sfondata a nudo allieva per certo la mia
seconda opzione
non vedo attenzione non sia chelsea come
non schiacciare quello che perdono
schiacciare velocissimo io la mia e
sposa stava al fiume senior cosa
schiaccio eva per quanto tempo il web
sul cloud ma non sapevo di cliccare non
vale sono pronto oddio
e va beh certo
sì sì sì non l'ha neanche ucciso per
caso il fucile sono frentzen di friendly
quello sì cacca addosso a spararmi va
bene c'è guarda che non ce l'ho la
prontezza di nuovo è solo di fare sei
mio di matrix
sono uscito bene be nice
beh non è stato male ending uno di tre
ovviamente facciamo anche le altre che
sono anche di qua potva sanavia d'altra
parte succeda qualcosa d'altro
attenzione questo non lo sapevo vado a
destra perfetto non succedevano stese io
mi metto a tagliare tutte le sbarre alla
porta al teoricamente dovrei riuscire a
crearmi un altro finale ce ne sono 3 1
di finale scaling prison cosa vedo tac
sprangate in bocca attenzione quello
dietro pure sono fenomeno sono chiuso
nella porta attenzione incredibile share
con la sedia
beh se è certo che la sedia rotta è
sempre il migliore dei modi a sinistra
le a sinistra
cosa sta succedendo l'ira di rompe
giorno comunque sono sfigato e se posso
dire ad essa si esce dal non si sa come
paracadute zio c'è paracadute perfetto
schiaccio perché l'ho detto prima che
uscisse quindi va bene sono meno
schiacciare una cosa non era un po anche
a tutte le uscite della coca cola delle
robe facciamo bloggers era l'ultima
ovviamente certo che li sturalavandini
mi sembra non era la mia prima scelta
ovviamente dovevo prendere quelli ove di
che alla fine molto più semplice be nice
qual è il terzo finale cell phone cell
phone si dice proprio ne ho chiamato
l'avvocato va bene 9 settembre vabbè
distretto dalla corte corte un numero 4
va bene va bene ragazzi ho completato
anche il terzo che lo riassumo
semplicemente in tribunale hanno detto
che mi hanno chiuso dentro il sacco del
dei soldi non mi ci sono messo io e
quindi mi hanno buttato dentro la banca
contro la mia volontà e poi sono uscito
questo è quello che una cagata all'esame
ragazzi se ti e piaciuto quasi giorno mi
piace anche vari social che condizione
se questo si chiede vi è né come sempre
ci vediamo ad un prossimo video bello
ragazzi
[Musica]